est ce que tu me reçoit jeu
question mais je te mets pas sur scène
je te mets 4 sur 5 parce qu'il ya des
grésillons aller
voici encore on l'a bien préserver la
planète des vôtres c'est municipaux
alors commencé à écrire mais la qualité
qui m'ont viré du monde et qu'on fait
rien cariat ans le plus jeune joueur ne
va pas se laisser faire
la révolte gronde la lutte que se
prépare elle à lui maintenant alors il
s'en sort moins la permanence ils en
font hors écart je te quitte
tu me quittes rafraîchie regarde toi
enfin personne n'en voudra vous prouvez
grève du zèle travailler tout le temps
en surrégime cette mesure mérite
réflexion
lever le verre si vous êtes accro
[Musique]
pourquoi on a des cas nous là pour
rester à west à la mode à l'intérieur
pour rester anonyme je le savais j'ai
pas osé le leader il faut les briser
menu un seul coup
et on gagne on est là anonymes hommes
c'est le maire sait que c'est du travail
de [ __ ] le bordel tout le temps et
c'est du boulot un pilotage de la
congédie mon but